- I caught a fish this big and now...
- I'm going to jail!
- Two fishermen have
been charged with crimes
after a cheating scandal
at the Lake Erie Walleye
Trail fishing tournament.
After the tournament
director opened the walleye
caught by Jake Ryan and
Chase Kaminski, he shouted
- [Director] We got weights in fish!
- [Fisherman] There we go!
- And as the viral video shows,
the fisherman loaded up their
catch with over seven pounds
of lead weights enabling
them to win the tournament
and the $28,000 prize.
Other fishermen became
suspicious of the pair
after they dominated the
walleye fishing season
all year long.
Ryan and Kaminski were indicted on charges
of attempted grand theft,
a fourth degree felony,
for trying to steal property,
valued at over $7,500.
They were also charged with cheating,
possession of criminal tools,
and unlawful ownership of wild animals.
The pair allegedly stuffed
other fish with fish filets
which is the basis for
the wild animal charge.
The local prosecutors
described the conduct
as not only dishonorable,
but also criminal.
No word on whether the
Lake Erie Walleye Trail
fishing tournament will ever
recover from the scandal.